hey so this is gonna be super short I'm
out in British Columbia right now I'm
outta Vancouver in Coquitlam and I just
wanted to get something up so that we
had something you know waiting for you
on Monday and keep with that schedule
and the the one thing that I wanted to
talk about real quick so he went to the
Vancouver Aquarium today we saw the
dolphin training the show and I was I
was watching them interact with the
dolphins and it was it was fascinating
because I want you to just just think
about that for a second the the language
barrier that needs to be overcome in
order to in order to achieve that level
of communication with the end the
instructions that they're able to give
to the dolphins are remarkably specific
and and complicated too there was one
that they were telling us about where
they would give a given instruction to
the dolphin that would basically be make
up your own routine of life like do four
things in a row but each thing needs to
be different than the last so you can
you know it's it's left to the dolphin
to decide what it wants to do but it you
know how how do they get to that level
of communication with these animals
that's that's that's mine Lloyd that's
fascinating and it says a lot about the
the capacity of intelligence in in
things that are just us and you know
what that's really cool that's really
awesome and it got me super stoked and
it was something something definitely to
think about and so that's just that's
gonna be our quick little thing we're
sorry about the sir about shortness of
it sorry about the the crappy image
quality sorry about the loud noise the
the air conditioning this this was
actually the quietest place I could find
and it's getting kind of late so I'm
just gonna leave it at that
thank you take care have a have a great
Monday